نبدا اسبوعنا بنشره اخبار اهل مصر على
فكره يعني خليني اوضح لكم حاجه للاخبار
اللي احنا بنعرض لكم هي يا دوب خلاصه ابرز
ما يتعلق فيه وتويتر لانه فعليا لا موجب
تصريحات والى تغريدات ولا تغييرات في
الشركه من يوم ما استلمها الرجال مستمر
المطلقه والرسوم عليها واليه التوفيق كلها
امور اتكلم فيها اكثر من مره اكثر من مره
عفوا من وقت اشترى تويتر
اعلن انه الشركه بتراجع الان اليه التوفيق
وتكلم كمان عن رسوم رح تفرض على الحسابات
الموثقه اللي هي ثمانيه دولار وفي
الويكاند رجع ماسك الكلام عن التوثيق
العناوين بتغريده اعتذر فيها عن التاخر في
اطلاق خدمه الحسابات الموثقه بحلتها
الجديده واعلن انه راح تطلق الجمعه المقبل
وراح يكون التوثيق انواع او الوان علشان
نكون ادق فجاه لانه الصحه الذهبي راح يكون
للشركات هو الرمادي للحكومات والمنظمات
الحكوميه اما الازرق خلال الافراد سواء
كانوا مشاهير او لا واعلن كمان انه
الحسابات الموثقه كلها راح يتم التحقق
منها يدويا قبل منحها التوثيق وقال انه
هذه خطوه مؤلمه لكن ضروريه بيقصد طبعا
مؤلمه انه يعني قديش اصلا صعب على فريق
تويتر بالنظر لكميه الحسابات الموثقه في
العالم وكميه طبعا الطلبات اللي جايه على
موضوع التوثيق ماسك لسه مكمل كمان في
التباهي فانا نشرت تغريده فيها شويه
احصاءات عن نجاح تويتر قال انه يعني بيحطم
ارقام غير مسبوقه في زياده اعداد
المستخدمين الجدد والدقائق النشطه
للمستخدمين وانخفاض مستوى خطاب الكراهيه
بس الموضوع ما وقف هنا ففي مغرده قالت انه
اذا جوجل وابل شال تويتر من متاجرهم
الالكترونيه باعتبار انه في ناس كثير
غلطانه من الماسك واللي بيعملوا في تويتر
فقال مغرده انه اذا شالوا تويتر من
المتاجر في ماسك لازم يصنع تليفونه الذكي
الخاص وقالت انه نصف العالم راح يستعمل
تليفونه ويترك الشركات الثانيه اللي
وصفتها بالمنحازه والمتجسسه وكانت السيد
كمان انه يعني ماسك بصنع صواريخ بتطلع
المريخ فاكيد ما حيستعصي عليه انه يعمل
تليفون صغير يعني ماسك رد عليها وقال انه
اتمنى ما نوصل لهنا بس نعم اذا ما كان في
خيار ثاني فانا مستعد اني انا اصنع تليفون
جديد السؤال هنا جدي ايش واقع هذا الكلام
فعليا ممكن بسهوله يعمل مصنع هواتف ذكيه
ينافس ايفون وهواتف اندرويد
اللي عنده بيتمكن
الوضع وجوابه للمغرب هذا هل ممكن نعتبره
مثلا تهديد للمتاجر الالكترونيه انه ما
يفكر يحضر تويتر ولا كيف نقدر ناخذه يعني
في تساؤلات كثيره خلينا نناقشها مع ضيفنا
اللي بينضم الينا من الرياض الخ التقني
عبد العزيز الحمادي اهلا فيك معنا عبد
العزيز قد ايش واقعي موضوع انه ماسك يعمل
تليفون جديد
يعني بصراحه اليوم انه شخص يعمل تليفون
جديد همم يعني ليس مستحيل همم يحتاج له
عشرات الملايين من الدولارات ومن ثم الشخص
يستطيع فعلا ان شاء الله همم جهاز الهاتف
جديد ينافس فيه في السوق همم بطبيعه الحال
هو همم رجل اقتحامي ان كان صاحب تعبير دخل
مجال الفضاء سكس عام 2002 مجال همم سيارات
همم القياده بشركه تسلا ونجاح فيها والان
فعليا همم يعني من يستغرب ان كان جاء بعد
اسبوعين وفعلا قرر انه يفتح همم شركه
هواتف الذكيه جديده الرجل همم لن يستغرب
عليه احد هذا الامر
ولكن بتقول انت انه ممكن انه يعملها بس
هذا الموضوع يعني سنوات اخذ ابل سنوات اخذ
الشركات الثانيه همم سامسونج هواوي وما
الى ذلك ف قد ايش فعليا هو يقدر خلال مثلا
وقت قصير انه يعمل تليفون جاهز من كل
النواحي يعني طبعا خرجت تليفون جديد
بطبيعه الحال يستغرق شهرين ثلاثه اشهر
والشخص يستطيع انتاج تلفون كل اللي يحتاجه
هو عباره عن شركه في الصين خط انتاج مثل
ما تسوي شركه ابل محمد صانع فاكس كان في
الصين على سبيل المثال ويحتاج النظام
الانظمه اليوم جاهزه ما يحتاج حتى بينا
نظام جديد سيقوم باستخدام همم النظام
الاندرويد مفتوح المصدر مثل ما تقوم شركه
سامسونج وشركه هواوي وعدد كبير من همم من
الشركات لكن هل سينجح هذا بصراحه ال-
السؤال الاهم اليوم شركات مثل ما ذكرتي
همم قيمتها بتريليون على حسب شركه ابل
القيمه السوقيه الاعلى على مستوى همم
العالم همم يعني لم تصل لهذه المرحله في
يوم وليله صرفتها عشرات السنين من وقتها
يعني قياس على قياس
بس اكس في طبيعه الحال في رايه ليس مقارنه
همم يعني همم صحيحه لانه في النهايه
لانه الناس جلسه بتقول اللي عمل تسلا وعمل
سبيس اكس مو صعب عليه
طبعا هو بدا فيها في وقت ما في منافسات هو
في النهايه يقوم بخدمه ناسا في ناس ليست
منافسه لها بطبيعه الحال دخل في مجال
سيارات ذاتيه القياده تسلم
وسيارات الكهربائيه لم يكن في منافسه
كبيره جدا في ذلك الوقت لذلك نجى لكن ان
يقوم بابتكار جهاز جوال في وقت همم يعني
هناك صراع كبير جدا ما بين الشركات العظمى
حق جوجل ويريد الوصول لها في سنوات قليله
وطبيعه الحال لا اتخيل انه ينجح والدليل
ذلك ان شركه هواوي حينما اختلفت مع شركه
جوجل همم في النتائج الكترونيه الخاصه
فيها وقامت شركه هواوي بارتكار المتجر
الالكتروني الخاص بها اللي هو هارمني او
اس حتى الان همم لم تنجح نجح كبير جدا
كثير من الناس الى درجه انهم يقومون ببيع
اجهزهم همم الهواوي بسبب انه لا يوجد فيها
الاب ستور فهل همم
خلال فتره قصيره حل ما لم تستطع شركه همم
هو قوي الوصول اليه وهي عمرها اكثر من 30
سنه حتى الان اتخيل صعب جدا في فتره وجيزه
حتى وان كنت تملك مليارات كثيره طيب احنا
بنشكرك على هذه المعلومات وعلوم ان احنا
هنشوف يمكن هو بس كان مجرد تهديد منه كان
معنا من الرياض الخبير التقني عبد العزيز
الحمادي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]